monsieur le ministre sous le quinquennat
précédent le pouvoir d'achat des
familles s'est considérablement héros d
abaissement du plafond du quotient
familial suppression de l'universite
alité des allocations familiales
abaissement des seuils de ressources
pour bénéficier de la page et réduction
de son montant le résultat ne s'est pas
fait attendre
le taux de natalité a baissé pour la
quatrième année consécutive la garde de
l'enfant de 0 à 3 ans est une source de
préoccupation le président de la
république annoncé récemment la création
de nombreuses places de crèche si je
loue la volonté je suis très réservé sur
les conditions d'application
les municipalités toucherait une
subvention annuelle de 2000 euros par
place de crèche créée à la condition que
les revenus des familles accueillies ne
dépasse pas 25 mille euros avec un
enfant 30000 euros avec deux enfants
le taux global d'accueil des enfants de
moins de 3 ans est le plus faible dans
les zones où le marché de l'immobilier
est tendu dans ces territoires
avec 2500 euros par mois pour élever
deux enfants et payer un loyer
vous êtes loin d'être riche dit
autrement votre gouvernement propose aux
mairies de créer des crèches réservé aux
familles pauvres
faisant fi de toute mixité sociale et
laissons de côté les familles modestes
quant aux objectifs fixés par la
nouvelle coche ils sont floues et laisse
les élus inquiets
la paix est sud n'augmentent pas ou si
peu entre 2019 et 2021
cette politique va empêcher la création
de places de crèche pire elle risque
d'en supprimer le reste à charge pour
les communes ne cessant de s'accroître
monsieur le ministre quand la france
aura-t-elle un gouvernement qui prendra
à bras le corps la politique familiale
pour la défendre et pour l'unifier merci
répondre la parole est au secrétaire
d'état auprès de la ministre des
solidarités de la santé monsieur le
ministre à part merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs madame la sénatrice christine
lagarde vous êtes bien placé pour le
savoir en tant que quatre jantes aux
finances de la municipalité de boulogne
billancourt l'accès des places en crèche
et de la compétence des devil nous avons
mis en place depuis le début du mandat
de nombreuses mesures favorisant la
mixité sociale dans les modes d'accueil
du jeune enfant et permettez-moi de
revenir sur un certain nombre de ces
dispositions que nous assumons le bouc
bonus mixité sociale tout d'abord et le
bonus territoire du clan pauvreté qui
encourage les gestionnaires et les
villes à accueillir des enfants
défavorisés en compensant leur manque de
recettes
la réforme du complément de mode de
garde ensuite par la mise en place
effective du tiers payant et la
suppression de la condition d'activité
pour des bénéficier de ce complément
mode de garde
et pour rendre ainsi l'accueil
individuel auquel j'imagine que vous
êtes attaché aussi accessible que les
crèches
mais l'attribution des places de crèche
doit également être plus transparentes
c'est sur ce point que je souhaiterais
insister aujourd'hui devant vous et je
remercie à cette occasion
elisabeth laithier en charge du dossier
petite enfance au sein de l'association
des maires de france et adjointe au
maire de nancy qui a travaillé remis un
rapport à la ministre
agnès buzyn et à marlène schiappa à ce
sujet en présence de françois baroin que
vous le vouliez ou non la situation
actuelle est insuffisante et
insatisfaisante par dont l'insuffisance
de l'offre d'accueil et la sur
représentation des enfants issus des
ménages les plus aisés dans les modes
d'accueil collectif alimente un
sentiment d'injustice sociale
en effet vous le savez seuls 5 % des
enfants de moins de 3 ans appartenant
20% des ménages les plus pauvres sont
accueillis en crèche contre 22 pour cent
des enfants des parents les plus aisés
la mission laitiers propose de mettre en
place une grille de critères
d'attribution sélectionnant des critères
pertinents parmi un large socle existant
en fonction des spécificités de chaque
territoire
ce vade-mecum décrit les différents
systèmes utilisés tels que la
priorisation la bonification ou encore
la pondération ses grilles pour être
adapté pour à contenu du suivi
c'est cette transparence et cette
diversité dans l'offre d'accueil qui
nous permettra d'assurer une meilleure
coordination des acteurs et je vous
rejoins sur ce point une meilleure
harmonisation des pratiques entre les
territoires
je remercie madame laborde oui monsieur
le ministre il me semble que vous n'avez
pas bien compris le sens de ma question
je voulais juste vous faire remarquer
que cette politique ne va faire
qu'accroître le français entre ceux qui
financent la presse les prestations
sociales et n'en bénéficient pas et ceux
qui les touchent
et comme vous êtes aussi un élu des
hauts-de-seine je vais vous inviter à
venir avec moi rencontrer les élus pour
percevoir les effets de cette politique
[Applaudissements]